all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with the
legend of blue marvel except this time
we start to focus a little bit more on
connor sims so what we do is we jump
back to 1953 at the naval amphibious
base in little creek north carolina
during the korean war and what you have
here is a fight that breaks out between
adam beshear and connor sims and a few
other guys and that's because they had
basically burned adam bashir in effigy
right and as a result of that conor sims
has taken just a personal affront to
that now what this does is it's designed
to show how close adam bashir and conor
sims were that they weren't really even
just friends they were more like
brothers and as a result of that conor
sim stated he would always have the back
of adam bashir because adam beshear had
saved his life and so as a result of
that we switch back to the modern era
right with this conversation between
adam and stark and reed hank pym these
guys and what happens is there's an
amazing conversation that goes on here
initially like tony stark and those guys
basically apologize and the response of
adam is i don't need your apologies for
what the federal government did to me 40
years ago right you weren't there you
didn't have a hand in it right i don't
need your apologies for that right let's
just focus on the here and now let's
focus on what needs to be done and let's
just move forward from here and so when
they basically explain what had gone on
with anti-man the response of adam is
like the avengers can't handle it and
they're like man we're lucky we even
made it out of that thing in one piece
we almost died fighting anti-man so no
this is not a problem the avengers can
handle like we need something like we
need you in order to handle this now of
course that's when the conversation
between adam and reed richards
illustrates the idea that anti-man is
basically a wormhole he's a way by which
the anti-matter universe can actually
cross over into the positive matter
universe and destroy the positive matter
universe and so that's when adam beshear
reveals the origin of both his powers
and the powers of conor simps and what
it reveals here is that there was a
basically a lab test that was being
conducted by the federal government
where they were looking to harness uh
antimatter energy as an infinite source
of energy because the anti-matter
universe is an entire universe so being
able to harness that infinite source of
energy would mean hopefully free energy
for everyone forever across the entirety
of the world the problem with that is
that antimatter energy is very difficult
to harness according to adam bashir and
impossible according to reed richards
and so ultimately the experiment went
awry now one of the things to focus on
here is that adam bershear's stance is
no the experiment just just basically
ended up going awry it didn't work out
the way that it hoped but you can
harness antimatter energy you can create
an antimatter reactor in the same way
you can create a nuclear reactor and
harness the splitting of the atom the
thing here is that with that whole
device and everything going nuts we
barely made it out alive but almost
immediately after that conor sims
basically just kind of broke down and
disappeared right he essentially just
vanished he says but the reality is that
there is like the the idea of an
antimatter reactor works you're looking
at it i am a living antimatter reactor
the difference here is that conor sims
is basically unstable so the way to
think about this is that adam bershea if
you were to use more realistic terms
adam bashir is a fully powered and fully
working nuclear reactor conor sims is a
nuclear reactor that kind of works but
is more broken or unstable than anything
else you never quite know exactly how
it's going to happen how it's going to
work so basically adam bershire achieved
exactly what he set out to do he's the
the perfect anti-matter superhero that
exists out there now one of the things
to also know here is that this is his
initial introduction into marvel comics
and as with most superheroes who are
introduced in comics you get an early
indication of what they can do with
their powers but over time those powers
will expand and that's why in the modern
era in marvel comics the powers of adam
beshear are largely believed to be
limitless and if given enough time he
could actually alter reality on a
universal scale whether he'll get to
that point we don't fully know but his
powers are immense it's why he was able
to go toe-to-toe with somebody like
galactus because it's just a limitless
source of energy that he channels from
and he could use it in a variety of
different ways it's most commonly used
for just your standard superhero powers
flight and speed durability and
invulnerability and so on and so forth
but his powers can be far more than that
with the right kind of writer and it can
be done believably and so as a result of
this the next time that conor sims had
reappeared was when he and adam beshear
were facing off against each other at
the beginning of the story and adam
beshear's mask was torn and the whole
country realized he was a black guy but
the response of iron man is i get that
that was a difficult thing for you and i
get that it's hard for you to face off
against your best friend and even ally
yourselves with us in the face of
everything that had happened but the
reality here is we need your help and
where he responds and says look i was
told my services were no longer needed
the response of ant-man is i still can't
believe you actually followed that order
and did nothing for all that time you
could have come out of retirement at any
time things got progressively better
after the king assassination and the
response of adam bashir is were you
there kumbaya did not happen overnight
dr pim people died for simply drinking
from the wrong water fountain given the
potential for a firestorm if i appeared
publicly i couldn't take that chance a
race war would have forced everyone to
choose sides make foolish decisions that
they didn't want to make and that
includes me laws exists for a reason to
prevent anarchy and when iron man asks
why are you simply just going to turn
your back the response of adam is one i
never said that i wouldn't help you guys
and two don't ever put words in my mouth
but one of the things to notice here is
that adam beshear is very hostile
towards reed and hank and and uh and
tony stark he's not very friendly to
them the the question that tony asks is
like what's with this guy's attitude man
like i thought he'd be happy and of
course hank kind of comes in initially
and says well i mean he's been a little
out of practice for 40 years and the
response of reed sort of observing
everything and putting his intellect to
the test here is saying like it's not
that simple right think about it from
his perspective he was a prisoner and
every aspect of his life had been
affected and has been affected by that
executive order whether he wanted to
believe it or not and were initially
hank's like that was a long time ago
reid right like you know things like
that don't happen anymore he needs to
learn to get over it the responsive read
is like is that so he's like for one
who's had his own bouts with anger
issues i'd have thought you'd been a
little more empathetic to that but let's
really draw let's let's look at what's
really going on here right let's look at
the bigger picture here reid kind of
scales out and says let's give you guys
some perspective and he says you know we
say that kind of of overt bigotry that
we had 50 years ago doesn't exist
anymore but we all know better like look
around our own community of superheroes
right let's just remove every other race
in existence let's just look at
superheroes for a second right the
avengers the fantastic four were lauded
as heroes protectors of mankind they
give us parades in our honor they
approach us for endorsements and all
kinds of stuff but the x-men who are
just as much the heroes as we are are
hated and feared have you ever asked
yourself why how does the world know
that we're not mutants yet because of
some warped perception and human idiocy
we get a pass while the x-men are
persecuted and the response of hank is
like well they were born like that reed
and that makes people afraid of what
they or their children could become and
the response of reed is but is that
really a good excuse to hate on him he's
like i admit i never much cared about or
even thought about mutant human affairs
until franklin was born because at this
point in time when the comic was written
franklin was still considered a mutant
in marvel comics he says as a mutant
there have been whole organizations and
government institutions that have been
built to destroy quote unquote his kind
and that's true right friends of
humanity the right different groups like
that project wide awake in its entirety
the entire government has actually
actively worked against the mutant
population in order to contain and
control it for fear of what the mutant
population might do if there are enough
of them in the world and he says my son
and now my daughter have done nothing
wrong except for the fact that they
exist to coin a phrase their skin is
their sin their dna is their crime and
so of course tony times in and says yeah
but i mean like other heroes have been
persecuted too i mean hasn't really been
peaches and cream for any of us and reid
says i realized that but look at the
blue marvel adam beshear even after the
cape comes off and the mask is put in
the closet even his humanity as a black
man was still a problem how would any of
us feel if that happened to us and that
really is the crux of why adam beshear
holds so much resentment here it'd be
different if it was a problem with his
costume it'd be different if his costume
was offensive but it wasn't the costume
of adam beshear that was offensive to
the federal government and the people in
the in the positions of powers that be
it was just the nature of adam beshear
himself it was his skin color something
he couldn't control and so as a result
of that adam beshear of course holds a
lot of animosity and so following that
conversation we switch over to adam
beshear traveling back to his base of
operations down in the mariana trench
right because he actually operated down
in the ocean and that's really where his
base of operations remained even after
this whole story came out and in the
middle of all this he's actually met by
neymar the submariner now what's really
funny here is that where reed richards
and tony stark and hank pam pitch this
idea that like well the world's not as
bad as it used to be you know things are
different now that name on the
submariner actually takes a wholly
different approach he takes the opposite
approach and he's just like no right
like the surface world are a threat to
my people you better believe if it came
down to it i would absolutely destroy
the service world my people come first
that's the choice that i make and it's a
really interesting thing here because
what namor says is that when i was with
the invaders right captain america the
original human torch jim hammond bucky
barnes he says we battled alongside red
tail pilots who face constant ridicule
and strife from both collaterals and
superiors alike accused of being stupid
inferior and unworthy they had to follow
orders yet they never turn their back
when the call went out and they were
some of the bravest americans i ever met
my point is no matter what the odds of
prayed against you there is a larger
picture to consider even if it's only to
inspire others to be great you're
sovereign of your own kingdom the rules
are simply different and the response of
namor is you forget yourself adam
remember in atlantis i was the outcast i
was the sub-atlantean pariah the
pink-skinned crota that means pale crab
in my tongue amongst a world of blue
skins i did not hide my abilities nor
did i run i stood strong for all to see
i ruled and they called me crawdad no
more and the response of adam here is
really intriguing he says don't be naive
they just don't say that to your face
and he says be that as it may they are
still my people and when the surface
people attacked atlantis i made them pay
for every drop of atlantean blood that
was spilled by attacking new york city
and so adam responded saying just
because you have power doesn't mean it
should be abused besides you can't
condemn a whole race because of the
actions of a foolish few and when neymar
asks who's being naive now he makes this
incredibly compelling point where he
says a foolish few left unchecked can
become an evil mini 11 million died
horribly how many lives might have been
saved had good men intervened earlier to
stop that atrocity and where adam says
this is different you're asking me to
make enemies of people who are my
friends people who have loved me
regardless of my skin color i can't even
imagine what you're suggesting the
response the final statement here
offered by namor is he says captain
america a surface dweller who was my
oldest and dearest friend who was as
much akin to me as a brother because
remember by this point captain america
is dead he says but where atlantis is
concerned my people friend or no i would
lay waste to the entire surface world to
protect them and he says i'm trying to
get you to understand the complexities
of justice if you want things to change
you're going to make enemies there's no
way you can invoke change in the world
in any capacity and not make any enemies
in the process and so it's really really
it's a is a phenomenal idea because what
this does is it leads to adam beshear
taking off to the moon presumably to see
the watcher we're not entirely sure but
he's suddenly met by the arrival of
conor simps and the the discussion
between the two of them really breaks
out insofar as there's a a bit of a
personal vendetta here in the sense that
because of what conor sims became
because of how violent he became and how
terrible he became insofar as wanting to
eliminate the entirety of humanity right
or force humanity to change that what
adam beshear did is he actually
organized the the wife and child of
conor sims to be moved to a safe
location so conor couldn't get to them
but conor saw it as adam bashir standing
in the way and actually preventing him
or at least taking away the things that
meant the most to him and so that's when
adam tells conor he says things are
better conor not like they were in like
the 60s they're not perfect but there
are good people on all sides who are
trying to come together you have to
believe in that and the response of
conor is that belief is misplaced and
you are naive for having it adam he says
i've walked this world in the short time
i've been back and that is far from true
everywhere i look man still hates his
brother be it the south the far east or
the middle east it's all the same adam
and it's your weakness that allowed all
of this and when adam asked the question
is it really my weakness that i chose
peace over violence the response of
conor is no it's because you chose to
turn your back when it was within your
power to stop this madness millions of
your own people left to suffer under the
yoke of oppression little girls who were
burned in churches by professed
believers men hung from trees like
strange fruit because they dared to look
their oppressors in the eye if you had
done something then perhaps i would not
have to do anything now and that's
really the crux and the nature of conor
sims one of the best things about this
story is that anti-man is not some kind
of villain of the weak guy it's not all
man i have these kind of anti-matter
powers i'm sure i'm a little bit
unstable in terms of my powers but i'm
gonna conquer the world because i love
having power no it's not like that and
in fact it's the other philosophical
side of the equation a more extreme
equation but still a logical equation
right the stance of conor sims and is
exactly what we talked about in the
first video the stance of conor sims is
that if humanity wanted to change
humanity would have changed there's
nothing stopping the human race from
changing but it's not like thanos used
the mind stone and is forcing humanity
to fight against itself you know based
on petty squabbles like skin color or
religious convictions or socioeconomic
status right it's humanity that chooses
to do that to itself the stance of conor
sims at least in this story is that's
how people are people don't want
anything to get better adam bashir and
your belief in the fact that they do is
foolhardy what you're doing here is
you're looking for reasons to believe
that humanity wants to be better in the
face of the fact that they don't now the
other part of this equation is that
conor sims has a huge negativity bias
because if adam bashir is basically
looking for reasons to believe why
humanity is worth saving conor sims is
looking for reasons to believe that it's
not and so both of these guys if if
we're being honest here neither one of
them is actually right but the truth is
they're both operating on two opposites
right then you have adam beshear who's
operating as an extreme optimist and
you've got conor since who's operating
as an extreme pessimist the question
that really has to be asked here is
based on these two ideologies if you had
to choose one which one would be right i
would argue that it's one of those
things where if humanity truly wasn't
worth saving then there would be no
volunteers there'd be no charity there'd
be there wouldn't be anybody out there
doing anything that's good the reality
is that there are people who are doing
that now ultimately conor sims gets the
upper hand on adam beshear knocks him
unconscious and says you had your time
adam you could have fixed the world you
could have made it better but you chose
not to and so in the face of the fact
that humanity will not fix itself i will
make humanity fix itself with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace